last week three eminent Australians
reflected on their younger years and
shared some heartfelt life advice to
inspire students the response to this
segment has been extraordinary and
you've told us you wanted more and so
tonight we're giving you just that
tonight we're hearing from Australia's
most famous teacher
Eddie boo I actually think that
following your pattern is a terrible
piece of advice because I think passion
is something that needs to be formed
over time with thought and care looking
at the things around you the situations
where there are needs in your community
Eddie Wu is an Australian mathematician
his head maths teacher a cherrybrook
Technology High School in Sydney and is
best known for his YouTube channel
YouTube what path is his theorem tells
us is that all these sites they're
related in this way in 2018 Eddie was
named Australia's local hero of the year
and was shortlisted as one of the top 10
teachers in the world he was also a
student once when I was a teenager I was
really confused I wished I knew who I
was and I had so much trouble trying to
picture myself as maybe I'm this kind of
person maybe I'm that kind of person and
a lot of my time and emotional energy
was spent on trying to be are the people
it's almost laughable now to say this
but I do not have and never had the
receipt to be athletic or strong but I
remember looking at people like that and
thinking gee I wish that could be me and
trying like I tried to push-ups every
day after school to try and develop my
big muscles which just never happened as
you can see my final years of high
school were a really difficult and
emotional time for me
the largest reason why was because my
mother was diagnosed with lung cancer
when I was at the end of year 10 and so
as a consequence years 11 and 12 we're
just completely colored by that
experience of trying to manage who I was
becoming my own identity academic
commitments and also being a carer so it
was not a fun part of my life in some
ways study became a little bit of a
refuge it was my time to spend away and
actually look after myself as a person
and do the thing I so much enjoyed which
was learning
I was not always good at maths and it's
always I'm still not in fact I think as
a teacher one of the greatest assets I
have is that ability to struggle I
teaching so much is about empathy it's
about putting yourself in the shoes of
the learner and being able to understand
what's their perspective I got on this
train when I arrived at University with
the full intent to become an English and
history teacher because those were the
subjects that I loved and had an
affinity for at school and I discovered
very quickly that actually literally
upon enrollment at Sydney University
that there was this huge shortage of
mathematics teachers something I hadn't
experienced as a student and I thought
look I want to become a teacher because
I want to make a difference in the lives
of young people well your parents good
at maths my mum she was actually a
newsreader and she could speak all these
different languages which for me was
amazing but she never you know made that
something was expected like I expected
you to be good at this because of that's
who I am
she just wanted me to take the
opportunities that would come my way and
make the most of them and so I'm just
grateful that they passed on that value
of Education and learning to me it's
been so formative in Who I am as a
person you know I lost my mom when I was
18 years old and I I didn't have this is
before phones were in our pockets that
could record all this video and I
literally actually can't remember what
the sound of my mom's voice is like and
that makes me really sad and I think
about all the times when I'll just race
out the door not paying attention to her
and I could have just sat and heard her
out and listened and paid attention to
so I heard people take that lesson to
heart because you never know when it is
that you have to say goodbye to people
who you really care about
I think everyone gets given their unique
gifts and it takes time to discover what
those are from your disposition from
your genetics from the opportunities and
decisions that you get given to to make
uniquely in your life so be patient that
will come out give yourself some time
and you never know what might come
around the corner will help you discover
your purpose in life
I love mr. Wu that thread grow tonight
thanks you company good night
[Music]